I recently took $50 and turned it into
over $3500
using this exact step process of growing
a small account into a large one that
I'm going to show you. We are going to
go through this stepbystep process of
what you want to do right now and how
you want to grow it over time. Now, the
first thing you need to do is find a
trading platform that you like. I highly
recommend going with the major ones.
They're pretty much all competitive
across the board with fees, but don't go
with the small one. A lot of the times
those are scams. The two big ones I
recommend are Trading View and Ninja
Trader. Ninja Trader I have used for
over 5 years now. And they've recently
started trading competitions to where
you can enter for free and get prize
pools of up to $400,000. And this is
just demo trading. Now, the problem with
trying to start a small account of,
let's say, $500 or less is you run into
the pattern day trading rule a lot of
the time. And what this means is that
you need at least to trade stocks is you
need over $25,000 in your account to be
able to trade more than five times in a
rolling 5day period. And so, basically,
as a day trader, you can't really trade
that often because of that. And so I
actually realized over time trading
options, forex, crypto, pretty much
everything out there, futures were
actually the best thing because they
were simple. I always traded options and
they were super complicated. Futures are
super simple. They're basically like
stocks. You buy it and it goes up, you
make money, and you sell it, it goes
down, and you make money. Versus
something like options. It's very, very
complicated even once you understand
them. Now, futures are a little bit more
complicated than just stocks, but they
also allow you to avoid that pattern day
trading rule. You can trade as much as
you want as day trades with a $500
account. So, it allows you to start
small, but also get crazy amount of
leverage. Futures trading has something
like 450 times leverage. And so this
allows you to start small but grow it
really fast just like I did recently in
that challenge where I took $50 over
about seven trades and turned it into
$3500. The leverage that you actually
have access to is insane. But if you
trade it properly, you can protect
yourself as well. Now the next thing is
riskreward ratios. When you start out
trading, do not fall in the trap of
trying to go for a high win rate. 95%
win rate sounds really good, but
majority of the time with those
strategies is they are a really bad
riskreward ratio is you're going for a
micro movement of let's say you risk
$100 and you go for making $25 in
profit. So your riskreward ratio is
inverse or negative. It's 4:1 where
you're risking $100 to make 25. And when
you win, you make a tiny amount of money
versus when you lose, you lose $100,
which wipes out four wins. And I fell
into this trap when I first started out,
and it really, really messed me up. And
so I highly recommend is flipping that
and instead at a minimum go for one:1
riskreward ratio of you're risking $100
to make $100 or up to higher ones where
it's one to three where you're risking
$100 to make $300. This really puts the
math in your favor and also that takes
the pressure off of every trade having
to work out. Even if in you're in a hole
of, you know, four or five losses in a
row, but if you have one win, you're
almost back to break even at that point.
And when you do win, it pays off a lot
more. But because of that, a lot of the
time your win rate is something like 30
to 40%. Which doesn't sound very good,
but in the math and world of trading,
win rate doesn't really matter by
itself. You have to know someone's
riskreward ratio and how much they're
getting on average per trade. And so
really focus on that and understand that
in the beginning it's not all about win
rate. Now the path to growing your
account is really important. I highly
recommend getting futures and getting
Ninja Trader and starting out on a demo
account. When you first start out
trading, it's really exciting. You could
make a lot of money, but likely you lose
a lot of money. A ton of traders come
into the space excited and they trade
something like futures and they lose a
ton of money right away. And what you
need to do is demo trade and find some
consistency with a strategy for let's
say one to two months and then from
there move on to trading real money. But
again, start out small and treat trading
and focus on the process when you first
start out. Don't focus on the money
because when you first start out, you're
going to be trading a small amount.
You're going to see all these traders on
YouTube making thousands and you're
going to have that FOMO. But what you
don't realize is they have spent years
practicing and starting out just where
you are with a small amount of money.
And that's the power of trading is you
can master one strategy and if you can
make $50 every day with it, well, you
can scale that to $5,000 every day with
it. But it takes time to get that
consistency and move up through that
process. And so that also goes down to
another big rule is do not focus on
daily goals and profit targets. Do not
go into every day with a daily goal of
making, let's say, $100 today or I'm
going to go for three trades today
because what this does is it sets
pressure on your trading to perform. And
when it comes to the market is you can
have days where the market is great and
you get 10 trades in one day and days
where you just sit on your hands and
knees and you don't want to do anything
today because the market just sucks. And
if you have a goal to make a certain
amount of money or take a certain amount
of trades, you're going to end up
forcing a trade on a bad market and it's
going to lose you more money. Now, when
it comes to scaling your account and
doing it properly, I highly recommend,
let's say you have a $1,000 account is
risking no more than 5% of your account
per trade. Because what this will do is
you could go on losing streaks and if
you, let's say, lose five trades in a
row, you will lose up to 25% of your
account. And that is pretty big, but
it's manageable and you can come back
from that. Especially if, let's say, on
a win you're making three times that,
you're going to make 15% return. And so
what this allows is you to go through
the ups and downs of the market. And
trading, when you first start out,
you're going to make losses and you're
make going to make mistakes. And if
you're risking too much of your account
at once, you're going to blow it. And so
I even suggest risking less than 5% if
possible. When you start trading futures
and trading the micro futures, you can
risk as little as sometimes $20 per
trade. And so that would really allow
you to start out really small when you
are trading real money. And from there,
you can slowly scale once you get your
profits going. Now, a huge trap that
everyone falls into trading, and I fell
into it for years, is you'll jump into a
video like this, and you'll find a
really cool strategy that seems really
good, and you'll practice it for a
while, and then it won't really work out
for a while, and so you will instead
switch to another strategy. You'll look
for another video, this strategy seems
good, and so you'll try it out. But the
problem is trading, there are infinite
ways to trade in the market. And so what
everyone is doing, someone can be
trading a strategy that works for them,
but it doesn't necessarily work for you.
Or there, everyone's just trading
strategies that works for them, but
they've spent years mastering it. And
there are so many videos, and even mine
included, that make the strategy look
really easy at a glance, but when you
try and execute it day in and day out,
there's a lot of little nuances that
come together that make you consistently
profitable over time. And so that's why
you have to stick to a strategy.
Otherwise, you'll get stuck in something
that I call the learning loop, and
you'll just be jumping from strategy to
strategy over and over. Instead, when
you're first starting out right now, try
and focus on not just a strategy, but
really just mastering the market
structure and mastering technical
analysis and just reading what the
markets do. If you're going to jump into
trading futures, focus on just
understanding how the NASDAQ and the S&P
500 move every day, you have to get the
reps in, of showing up day in and day
out, of watching the market open, seeing
how it moves. The market will go through
cycles of really crazy movement, kind of
choppy movement, and then, you know,
really one directional movement. And you
have to be able to learn how to adjust
between those because you'll be trading
one market where your strategy might
work really well and then it'll shift
and you will take a ton of losses
because now you'll be trying to use your
strategy in a market that doesn't really
work very well. And so that's where
those nuances will come in and help you
become a better trader. And so a huge
thing is you want to create a plan. You
want to create a plan where you come
into the market every day looking for a
certain strategy. What really worked for
me is I tried to trade multiple
strategies at once of reversals,
continuation trades, you know, short
trades, big trades, multiple time
frames, and it's just a lot at once. And
it seems like, well, this will give me
more opportunities and I'll make more
money. But when it really comes to it,
you need to just master one strategy.
That's what's going to make you
profitable. And so, you want to stick to
one strategy. What works for me is
looking for reversal trades every day in
the first 60 to 90 minutes of pretty
much the S&P 500 futures and the NASDAQ
futures. And that's all I do. And I just
move on with my day if nothing happens.
And I'll look for these key timing
reversals where the first 15 minutes of
the market open, the first 30 minutes
really a lot of the time those will
reverse. I'll watch news and then also
I'll watch about 90 minutes after the
market opens. That's when potential key
reversals happen as well. And if nothing
happens, then I'll move on with my day.
But I'll show up, look for those key
levels where I think they could reverse
and take a trade off of it. And if I
don't, again, I move on with the day.
That's what you really want to do with
trading is focus on one thing and wait
for the market to come to you. You do
not want to be reactionary to the
market. I've gone through down swings
where it feels like I'm being more
reactionary to the market and it causes
a lot more losses. And so this jumps
into another massive key when it comes
to trading is you need to journal your
trades. In some ways, even though you
can technically back test a strategy,
it'll tell you how profitable it is. And
on a demo account, you'll be able to be
really profitable right away potentially
with a strategy. But when it comes to
real trading, emotions are involved.
You're going to have fear that you're
going to lose money. You're going to
have greed out of how much money you
think you can make. And so you have to
journal what strategies and structures
are working so you can refine your
strategy over time. But you also need to
journal your emotions that you're having
because over time those are going to
change, but they're also going to help
you identify what is affecting your
trading. Everyone has different emotions
and negative patterns that they do that
will cause them to not follow their
strategy very well. A quick example is
recently for me I saw a massive
downtrend in the market and I wanted to
bet that that market was going to
reverse because I saw that there was a
huge downtrend and my emotions thought
well if I can catch this whole downtrend
reversing I will get like a five or 6x
and I'll make thousands instead of I
know for my strategy and observing the
market over years is that when there is
enough momentum in the market, it's
unlikely to reverse and so I need to
just sit out of the trade. But my
emotions and impulses got the better of
me and I jumped in on a trade anyway and
it ended up losing, of course. And so
what I've made is a sheet that I put on
my desk every day. And what it basically
has is some rules that I know that I
like to commonly break. These aren't
necessarily my trade entry rules of
waiting for a key level, waiting for the
trend to reverse, you know, a couple
patterns to show up. Those are my
standard trade entry rules that I don't
break because I've done them so many
times over and over. But what actually I
do break is I like to like I just said
that first one where if there's a big
trend that has strong momentum that is
unlikely to reverse, that means I should
not be taking a trade. And so if there
is that, I don't take a trade. Or if
there is a strong flush, that means kind
of like the market's done a final failed
breakout and it's baiting people in the
opposite direction. And I find that as a
good signal to jump in versus jumping in
on a, you know, a slow bottom in the
market. And then other basic things is
is the major trend aligned and is the ES
and the NASDAQ aligned. I've realized
over time is if there is a divergence
between those two, it's unlikely to work
out. And then after that, it's just
looking at what I see as the market
trends in either direction. My bias for
the day because I've realized over time
that as well is my read on the market is
really what my edge is. If I have a
strong read, then there is a really good
potential that I'm going to choose the
right direction and pick a good trade.
And if there isn't and I kind of have on
this one on this day I kind of have
either marked down for a lot of those
and so that means I really shouldn't be
trading and there's a lot of choppiness
and so I did actually stay out of the
market because it ended up being choppy
but I still stayed and watched the
market. So this is something that you
should do too is over time is understand
what mistakes you make and bring that to
your trading. That is the real key to
growing your small account into a large
one. This is what will make you
consistently profitable over the long
run. And so something I have that will
really help you is a 90-day trader road
map. It's a free downloadable guide that
will give you a ton of resources,
stepbystep process, more detailed on
what you should be doing every day to
grow and start your trading career. And
if you want a good explanation of how
futures work, how my trading strategy
works, and market structure, check out
this video right here. It'll be a full
course on everything you need to know
when it comes to trading.